cocaine puppies drunken mice transgender
monkeys
fist fighting hamsters and pigeons with
a gambling addiction
this isn't looney tunes these are all
victims of real-life scientific studies
paid for by you the american taxpayer
for decades dr anthony fauci's national
institute of health has taken your money
and used it to fund dozens of twisted
experiments here are just a couple
they've spent over 2.3 million injecting
beagles with cocaine
they sent nearly a million bucks to a
south american university to train mice
to binge drink booze in the dark
fauci just gave over 200 g's to scripps
research to create
transgender monkeys
by injecting males with female hormones
the reason
to study hiv rates in transgender women
really
they paid a college in portland oregon
almost a half a mill to teach pigeons
how to play the slots
and they've spent three million dollars
on a hamster fight club
they paid northeastern university
researchers to juice up hamsters with
steroids and cocaine and made them brawl
why
to study roid rage
thankfully peta got the hamster fight
club shut down
and it's not just animals they're doing
research on they're working on humans
too
the nih is bribing gay and transgender
boys as young as 13 to report their
sexual conquests
and this is without parental consent of
course
these frivolous studies sound like they
were conceived by mad scientists on an
acid trip what a sadistic abuse of
taxpayer money
except for the hamster fight club which
i'd watch
just kidding
joining me now vice president of public
policy for a white coat waste project
justin goodman
all right justin let me just start with
the transgender monkeys they don't need
an identity crisis you're injecting them
with hormones they just want to scratch
and swing from trees why would they do
that
the nih is addicted to spending
unfortunately animals and taxpayers have
been paying the price for decades as you
said uh the nih wastes about 20 billion
with a b 20 billion dollars a year on
these types of wasteful animal
experiments that range from the stupid
like putting fish on treadmills to
the sadistic like scaring monkeys with
fake snakes and spiders something
happening right now at a cost of 50
million dollars to taxpayers our group
exposed that wait wait they're scaring
monkeys with snakes they can get scared
in the jungle like that why do we need
to spend 50 mil on it
they want to know if you suck out a part
of the monkey's brain that controls fear
how they'll respond when you put a
rubber snake or a rubber spider well you
know what i'll save him 50 million if
you suck out the brain part that feels
fear they're probably not scared and
fish on a treadmill i mean my
treadmill my 10 month old knows that's
dumb
yeah
and some of it's just downright scary
like the experiments in wuhan that
anthony fauci was sending money to i
mean people should understand that those
are animal experiments also yeah and and
where are they getting the cocaine to
give to the beagles
the dea has a stash that they provide i
think
so wait so they seize narcotics from
the cartels and then they just hand it
over to fauci and he cuts up a few lines
for some beagles
i i don't know the details of it but i
think they do have they do maintain a
stash of cocaine just for experiments
like this they
i think they're doing the heroin
and coming up with these wicked
experiments why was the with the dog
wearing a lab coat by the way
they they fit the beagle puppies these
are six-month-old puppies and they fit
them with these coats that infuse
cocaine directly into their into their
veins because obviously they're not
going to snort it a cocaine vest i think
i know what i'm getting gut filled for
christmas
i'm joking but it's not funny it's it's
it's sad it's really sad
and it's a total waste of money i mean
we could use the money bacon's ten
dollars now it's unbelievable i think
fouchy should give the money back and
the cocaine to be perfectly honest and
we have a report on fatchi coming up
later in the show and we're going to
have you back on because i think it gets
worse thank you so much
justin thanks jesse hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else